so just to give an example of what i
mean here uh let's look at one
particular
uh computer game and some of the kind of
problems with
these identity phantasms that we find so
this is a game
called elder scrolls 4 skyrim so how
many people are familiar with
with this game right yeah so i would say
about 40 percent of people
raised raise their hands here and so for
those who
aren't familiar but it's a extremely
popular game and this is a narrow lens
for discussing its uh
impact but you could think about it this
way on the
on its best weekend star wars made seven
million dollars right
so star wars adjusted for inflation now
made 27.2 million dollars on its best
weekend
now a skyrim on its first day of release
adjusted for inflation so today
made 217 million dollars on the first
day
right so so again that's a kind of
narrow lens but just to give a sense of
the kind of scope of this medium
and its relationship to say the film
industry
so in this best-selling role-playing
game
there's some interesting phenomena where
characters such as the nords the
ostensible norwegians
or the red guard the ostensible african
characters within the game
are subjected to a form of stereotyping
so just in terms of description
the red guards are described basically
in the senseless stereotype of the black
athlete
they're called quote the most talented
warriors in tamriel
the red guard are also physically
blessed with hearty constitutions and
quickness of foot
and so basically in game playing terms
it translates into bonuses to their
running and jumping abilities as you
begin to play throughout throughout the
game
so how many people who have played
oblivion have also played the sequel
skyrim right there so a couple of people
here so
those who have played the sequel yeah so
this is a deep i should mention you can
there's such a fine grain of
customization you can do with these
avatars this is a default before
anything has changed but you can change
you know the shape of the bridge of the
nose and the flare of the nostrils and
yeah and skin tone you can change it in
a an immense number of ways
and so the default red guard in skyrim
do you think that the situation
has changed improved so do you remember
what it looks like
right so it's a topic i've been writing
about for for a little while anyway the
217 million
dollar the sequel is selling sql i
mentioned
skyrim actually the default avatar looks
like this now
so before you make any change to it
but so but what i would claim is that in
fact
this uh this avatar
[Music]
is neither better nor worse right so why
is it neither better
nor worse right well this is the reason
because this is just the front end right
this is just
the graphical uh front end there's been
a number of critique of this it's not as
if it doesn't matter critique of lower
crops body image and tomb raider and
this sort of thing
but what i'm interested in is the back
end focusing on the values that's on the
in the backend data and so i'll tell you
just a little bit about
uh about my interest in this
and so when we begin to look at these
attributes for strength intelligence
willpower agility
that determine your abilities within the
game so for example
your your abilities to to fight or
or to exhibit stealthy behaviors or
magic and so forth
well let's just take a look at this
particular role for intelligence
and notice that you happen to be the
norwegian the ostensible norwegian nord
that i mentioned
well you're 38 points uh intelligence
that's 20 points less intelligent than
the bretons the ostensible french within
the game
yeah right right yeah the imperials are
the
the romans you know they sort of stand
in for the romans similarly the red
guard are also 20 points less
intelligence
intelligent than the bretons if you're a
orc female you're
10 points more intelligent by default
than your male counterpart right
right so you have a number of these kind
of values that are just built into the
infrastructure of the game
now this can change over time you can
practice some behaviors more than others
and get better at skills you might not
be optimized for but many players are
are what are have been termed in the
literature and game studies
achiever players that means they want to
maximize all the statistics of their
character
within the game and if they play this as
one of these type of
races they never can do so but of course
this is just default stats so let's look
a little bit deeper under the hood of
some of these games
this is another game called neverwinter
nights which is an older game
and also a bestseller and so let's begin
to look at the data structure to
represent characters
within this and so there is a data
structure for
race sometimes people think this is my
glass you know if you look in the
technical
documentation you know the the the data
structures actually are called your race
phenotype and so forth
and so when you when you change the the
race within
with the data about race of your
character should that impact the way
that your character looks
so yeah so some people are nodding their
their heads but
in fact changing the race will not
change the appearance of your character
but many items have racially based
bonuses and what about phenotype
what should that represent i'm sure you
have a number of ideas about this
but probably you didn't think that it
just determines of whether your
character is of normal shape or a larger
shape what about gender how many genders
do you think are represented in the data
structure within this game
right so people say that too sometimes
people guess
you know one or three in fact it's a
five
there are characters that are male
female both other
and none although although
if you happen to to be male both other
or none you have a male body type
so five different genders eighty percent
of which
are male right and
uh yeah so so these kind of issues uh of
course they're just
again like a phantasm people are
building these systems that are based
on the world views that are out there
sometimes it's conventions
are around the the medium and so what
we're trying to do is develop systems
that are
more flexible and nuanced in terms of
how you represent these kind of issues
also allow creative critical engagement
with them
and one final thing i'll say i'll say
before going on to what our systems uh
do in this area is that these it's uh
not just the kind of casual interest
because
uh most people have some type of virtual
identity these days whether it's
e-commerce account account a social
networking profile
or avatar in a virtual world or game and
these impact our real world
a real world engagement with each other
so we've done studies say of
more than 1400 people in which we found
that in using a
learning game the kind of avatar you
have actually impacts performance and
engagement significantly
uh at stanford where i've been working
for the year uh jeremy baylenson is a
professor there
who's found it has a kind of theory
called the proteus effect with his
former student uh nicky
that suggests that people change the
real world behavior based upon their
avatar's behaviors
so if you use an attractive avatar you
actually change your interpersonal
distance with others uh
in the in in the real world or you might
change your exercise behavior if you
exercise within the virtual world
so he actually looks at the ways in
which real world changes to your real
world behavior
occur based on just having a different
type of avatar in a virtual world
you